[Music]
[Applause]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
so
[Music]
hello i'm nicholas thompson i'm the
editor-in-chief of wired
thank you so much for joining us on this
third
and final installment of wired25 it has
been
a fantastic virtual series so far i have
learned a ton
i hope you have as well every time i
watch that video i'm made nostalgic but
at least this week there's a little bit
of news that dance and dog
spot from boston dynamics it's now
actually out in the world the one we saw
out on the embarcadero
last year it's now in singapore
patrolling a park
to make sure people keep social
distancing you can buy one yourself
there's one spot in the wild and uh
canada you probably saw it on the
internet the other night
so very exciting to see spot
out there speaking of spot solving
problems today is all about
solving problems it's the wired problem
solving day
of wire 25 we're going to talk to people
who are
working on infrastructure who are
working on public health we're working
on
election security which everybody who
watched the debate last night
could not be more important how do you
keep
an election safe how do you sustain
democracy i'd like to thank our sponsor
vonage
for making this possible for allowing us
to gather virtually where once we
gathered in person
we're going to talk about a bunch of
different things specifically today
we're going to talk a lot about the
fires we have a great new cover story
for wire the fire next time by daniel
duane
5 million acres have burned out west
some of it because of climate change
but some of it because of policies that
can shift
they can be improved that we can do
better so we're going to discuss
that today we're also going to be
talking a lot about the pandemic
are we talking to scientists hackers
journalists are we talking to audrey
tong taiwan taiwan's digital minister
one of the reasons why taiwan has done
so well
with coronaviruses because of the way
digital democracy works there seven
people seven seven single digit
have died in taiwan because of the
coronavirus so the very important
conversation coming up there
but we're going to start with the
american response i'm going to start
with the person
most responsible for all the good things
in the american response
who's leading our vaccine effort who's
become the most trusted voice
in government so let's begin the last
day of wire 25
with dr anthony fauci thank you ever so
much
thank you so um i want to thank dr
falchi for joining us
uh you know we're very excited to have
him here at
the virtual wired25 uh dr falchi are you
there
it's okay that's uh
it's a little more virtual than i
thought um uh
so uh while we're having some audio
problems
um i gonna
tell you that i'm gonna vamp a little
and say that uh
dr falchi is gonna uh
talk i hope about the
pandemic with okay um i guess we're
shutting down a little
while we wait for dr falchi i hope that
uh our audio does
better than we've done with the pandemic
all right okay dr falci are you there
i'm here i can you hear me now
i can't you know we're wired right you
know
so of all the places we've got all the
connections
it's the wired one which ran into
trouble
sorry about that i hope you can hear me
clearly now
i can hear you crystal clear thank you
so much for being here
my pleasure good to see you
so here we are october is right on us
seven months into this pandemic
and the numbers are rising again and
some states it's the highest ever
uh we've had a terrible toll 200 000
plus deaths it's
the flu season is starting how should
americans be looking
at the situation now as the weather is
getting cold
and you know as i mentioned the flu
season's starting
and we're entering this new phase of
this ongoing pandemic
well obviously if you look at the
numbers
it's a very challenging and serious
situation because
the baseline of infections each day
are stuck now at around forty thousand
when we had our big spikes earlier on
months ago that were dominated at first
by the situation in the northeast part
of the country particularly the new york
metropolitan area
when that hit hard and then
came down to a baseline the baseline
never got down
to what i would consider a reasonable
level it was about 20 000
cases per day when we tried to so-call
open up the country to try and get the
economy back
a couple of months ago particularly in
the southern states
that were variable in how well
they abided by the principles
of the public health measures of opening
the economy
we got into trouble and we had cases
each day
that peaked at around seventy thousand
and now we've come down to about forty
thousand the reason i give you those
numbers
is that if you're going to enter the
challenging season of the fall and the
winter
where some things if not many things
will have to be done
indoors rather than outdoors you really
intensify the problem as well as the
fact
that we have to deal with an influenza
season as you mentioned
so i would have hoped that when we go
into the fall season
we would have had a baseline that was
really much much lower
than 40 000 cases so even though if you
look
at the map of the country there are some
areas of the country that are doing
quite well
but as a nation we're very diverse we
have multiple regions multiple
uh climates demographies and things like
that
that there are areas of the country now
that we're starting to see the
upticks maybe from people coming back
from vacation maybe from the college
students maybe from the post
labor day weekend but we're seeing in
certain parts of the country
upticks and test positivity which is
generally a bad prognostic sign for
you're then going to start seeing more
cases
more hospitalizations and then the late
effects
of perhaps even more deaths so we have
got to now
and i want to be clear with you because
whenever i say this
people sometimes misinterpret that i'm
saying we've got to lock down the
country we're not talking about
shutting down anything we're talking
about taking a very prudent
careful approach to reopening the
economy
by the common five or six things wearing
masks
uniformly avoiding crowds
keeping distance doing things outdoors
absolutely much more preferentially than
indoors
and washing your hands frequently it
sounds like
rather simple things but they do have a
major
impact on whether you can get those
surges
to come down so your question about the
flu season
we now have enough flu vaccine to
vaccinate
almost 200 million people everybody
six months or older should get a flu
shot
and if we do and abide by those public
health measures
that i just mentioned we might mitigate
well
the flu season and let me show you why i
think that's a possibility
our colleagues in the southern
hemisphere in australia
south africa and argentina particularly
in australia
because they were careful about mass
using distance crowds
as they entered their winter which is
april
to the end of august so they just
finishing
their winter now they had almost a
non-existent
flu season the first time in memory
that they had such a low flu season and
the reason
is they abided by the public health
measures
that i just mentioned so as we enter the
flu season
get your flu shot and please pay
attention
to those very simple public health
recommendations
that segues into a question we have from
a friend of wired uh
bill gates uh you know i know you you're
familiar with
um he thanks you for your leadership
yeah
and he has a question for you he says uh
bill says my question is whether or not
you're seeing seasonality with covid
as we see in other coronavir viruses
or seasonal influenza right and you
talked about how the southern hemisphere
is dealt with it through their winter um
do we
we haven't seen that or have we uh you
know
seeing how the numbers worked and if not
why do you think that is
no the numbers the numbers are telling
us just the opposite of that
because remember as we went
from the late winter early spring of
march
april may there was a question that as
we get into the
hotter months of june july
and august would there in fact be a
substantial diminution
of infections in our climate zone
namely the northern hemisphere and it's
very clear we didn't see that
there clearly a seasonality of the
common cold
coronaviruses but right now we should
not have and did not
and the i think the numbers proved it
that we did not see
a major dip in the infection
as we went through the summer because
just like i told you
we had those surges in florida
which was hot and humid during the
summer months
and that's when they went up to the
really big surge that accounted for the
country-wide
uh numbers of 70 000 new infections
throughout the country
as we were in the summer months so the
answer to my good friend bill's question
is
we've not seen seasonality with this
particular outbreak
so i understand with a novel virus
advice changes as we learn more about it
but sometimes
in this case it's difficult to nail down
what we know at a given moment
can you put the rest the confusion about
whether the virus spreads
by aerosols around in the air as opposed
to droplets that are propelled and fall
the ground or surfaces
as you know the cdc said yes and then
they walked it back
um people some people thought politics
might be involved
can you tell us what the answer to that
is in terms of aerosols
and what it means for us as we try to
avoid getting infected
right okay so there are a couple of
things that have helped to clarify
the answer to that question partially
but i think
satisfactorily and then a part that we
can answer
first of all when you talk about aerosol
classically that means something that
comes
from the respiratory tract and instead
of in the
droplets of a certain size fall to the
ground within a few feet
that accounts for the six foot distance
recommendation there are particles that
are small enough
or in an area when you look at the
dynamics of airflow
they don't just drop they hang around
for a while
for several seconds to minutes so that
you don't have
that kind of uh dynamic where all you
need to do is to stay distant
that's one of the reasons why we're
going to get to in a second
why it's important to wear masks
particularly and even when
you're indoors so the idea that there
are aerosols when you talk to the
aerosol
physicists to study this there seems to
be no question
that an element of the transmission
is aerosol when you look at some of the
epidemiological studies such as
in a restaurant where you have people
seated far away from each other
who could not have been in the range of
a droplet
that is going to be close enough to
transmit
who've actually gotten infected which is
epidemiological strong
suggestion that there is aerosol spread
so the answer i'll make it a two-part
answer to your question
the first do i believe that there is
aerosol that is transmitting as part of
the transmission
and my answer is yes based on what we
know about
aerosol physics and we're learning from
the physicists
who do this full time as well as
epidemiological data
what we don't know is to what proportion
of what level of impact aerosol
plays in transmission it is likely
that it is not the major form of
transmission
that the major form is still that
droplet type of transmission from person
to person
in close contact but the data that i see
get me feel i believe pretty confidently
that there is some element i can't tell
you if it's
2 5 10 but there is an element of
aerosol transmission which i don't think
is the dominant form of transmission
so so i take it you're not going to a
bar anytime soon
well no and i'm glad steven that you
brought that up because when you're
talking about
in a crowded place where people tend
not to wear masks and you're indoors
that's a perfect setup for any kind of
transmission
larger droplet transmission as well as
aerosol and in fact
when you look at the hot spots of
transmission
when you've seen people crowded at bars
with no masks
that's when you start to see the uptick
of test positivity
which leads to increased cases and then
increased hospitalizations
and then the vulnerable people who get
serious illness
get in trouble so let's talk about
vaccines for one
so we have four vaccines now that are in
phase three which means these randomized
clinical tests with
tens of thousands of human volunteers um
but while the speed is unprecedented
it's also causing some disquiet
like the name of the program itself is
operation warp speed
which is named after a make-believe form
of transportation
that violates the laws of physics right
i think
i'm totally in on vaccines in general
and god knows i am desperate for
protection
but i confess personally i'm among the
people who the polls say
is now over half the population that
fears that the first vaccine coming
along
will be released because of maybe
political concerns rather than science
is that fear reasonable well
the fear is understandable but if i give
you the facts
i would hope that you would see that in
many respects it's not reasonable but
it's understandable based on
sometimes confusing messages that go out
there
so so thank you for giving me the
opportunity
to try and clarify it so first of all
getting back to what you said stephen
i agree when i heard the word warp speed
i kind of winced
because that can suggest to some
irresponsible speed but it's not
so the time element of how we were able
to get
to phase three trials that you mentioned
there are now actually
five candidates that are in phase three
one is
on hold because of an adverse event that
has taken place in the uk but let's say
four that are operational the reason we
were able to get
to that in a matter of months as opposed
to years
is a reflection of the extraordinary
technological advances
in vaccinology that have allowed us to
do that
to go from the sequence of a virus on
january the 10th
to starting work on a new type of a
platform to going into a phase one trial
in 60 some odd days
instead of a few years to going into a
phase three trial
six months later that we started the
first ones
on july 27th was not
compromising safety it was not
compromising
scientific integrity it was a reflection
of scientific advances coupled with
financial risks so what do i say
what do i mean when i say financial risk
so in general vaccinology
when the companies do this they
cautiously
do one step after the other after the
other
in sequence we are doing things in
parallel
so before we have the answer to a
we invest the money in b and before we
get the answer to b
we invest money in c that's called
at risk again a bad terminology
because it isn't risk to the patient
it's risk
to the money so that you start preparing
for a trial
long before the previous trial is
proven to be successful you start
making doses of vaccine
before you even know it works
so if it does work you save months
if it doesn't work you lose a lot of
money
and the thought being that the federal
government
is saying we'll take the chance of a
financial loss
in order to get the process to be done
in a speedy but measured way
so that you don't cut corners on safety
and you don't cut corners on scientific
integrity
that's the speed but there's another
question
that well i know you want to ask it so
let me go in is that what about the
decision
of whether or not it's safe and
effective the big elephant in the room
stephen
is is there political influence saying
get something out
that isn't necessarily safe or that
isn't necessarily effective
the way the system is set up there is
independent
bodies that have access to the data
that no one else has access to and they
make the decision
based on the scientific data whether the
vaccine is safe and effective that's
called a data
and safety monitoring board that is a
board made up
of clinicians vaccinologists
statisticians
ethicists they are the only ones
in the form of the unblinded as it were
statistician who intermittently look at
the data and they can come to
any of a number of conclusions they can
say at a predetermined time by looking
at the data
it hasn't met the specifications in the
protocol for efficacy
so continue the study for another x
number
of months or it can look at the data and
say
my goodness there are more infections in
the vaccine
limb of the protocol than the placebo
limb you better stop
the study because it's dangerous or
they'll say we've looked at the data and
in fact
the vaccine is indeed providing the kind
of
protection that's statistically
significant
so now the company gets access to the
data
they go to the fda and the fda examines
it
independent scientists examine it
together
with their advisory committee which is
another independent committee
and then they make a recommendation
whether they have an emergency use
authorization
or a bla which is a biological license
application
now if they're trying to be an end run
around that
politically that will be so transparent
because all of that information will be
available to the scientific community
to people like myself and all of my
scientific colleagues
so there's a lot of fail-safe issues in
there
that are going to prevent going too fast
going too recklessly or doing something
prematurely
so when is your expectation
that this is going to happen some of
them you know the
optimistic maybe over optimistic uh
expectations we've been hearing from the
administration is
in a few weeks in october um yeah you
know can maybe
we'll start getting inoculated uh before
the end of the year
um right other people you know in the
government are saying
really not until next summer can we
really expect that to happen what's your
guess
no no no that's stephen i'm glad you
brought that up because there's some
there's some confusing messages there
let me march through it with you if
you'll allow me to do it
so right now with the vaccines that are
in advanced phase three clinical trial
there's a lot of people in those trials
i mean the moderna trial has 30 000
people
the fisa trial is 44 000. the johnson
trial has 60 000 so there are a lot of
testing going on there we're projecting
that given the level of infection that
we're seeing in the sites
in this country and in some cases
internationally
where infection is ongoing that my
projection in that of my colleagues is
that it is likely
that we will know whether we have a safe
and effective vaccine somewhere around
november and december
is it conceivable that that might be
before then
namely october it is conceivable
i believe unlikely but i wouldn't be
that surprised if it were because
the the answer to the trial is based on
how many infections take place in the
context of the trial
and whether the vaccine is
quite protective versus obviously the
placebo which you wouldn't expect
to be protective so let's assume that we
get an answer
in november and december as i mentioned
a little while ago the government has
already invested in
making hundreds of millions of doses
already they're working on it now so
there will be available
at the end of the year in december you
know about a hundred million doses
as you get into january february march
april
it'll be up to 700 million doses
by the end of april so if we have
if because remember we got to prove it
first but if we have a successful
vaccine
at the end of the year we would be able
to start
administering vaccine to the people who
are at the highest
priority which is determined
by an independent board by the time you
get to april you will have enough
vaccine from all of the companies
to be able to administer essentially to
everybody in the country
practically speaking when do we think we
actually will logistically get the
vaccine
into people who want to get the vaccine
or who might want to wait and see how
the trials go
practically speaking stephen it likely
will be the second
third quarter of 2021 but the beginning
of the administration of the vaccines
likely could take place at the end of
this year
or the beginning of next year okay we
have an audience question from
uh steve stoneburn uh were viewers
well served or poorly served by the
coveted q a
at last night's debate
um well
i think that the viewers of that would
likely not really have a clear-cut
picture of what was going on
i i don't i don't think i mean i don't
want to start getting into sound bites
but that was an unusual experience that
debate
was your you know your name was invoked
several times
were you comfortable with the
characterization of the president
talk to bu about you he said at one
point
you congratulated him for saving you
know
uh a hundred thousand lives by you know
the
limited uh travel from china then he
said that you
changed your minds about mask you said
messes are not good and then you said
masks are good
um he said to you specifically in that
do you want to
clarify anything no i i could i could
clarify that
um but let me first say that uh you've
probably heard me
speak a lot uh steven uh you know
tv and radio and press um i must have
said
maybe several tens of thousands of times
the importance
of wearing masks it's like when people
see me
when i'm walking or running in the
street with my wife and i have my mask
on they see me
they put their mask up because they know
it's me so
i'm the mask guy all right i don't think
there's any doubt about
that so if there was an interpretation
that i'm not for masks that's a
misinterpretation but let me get to your
question
so there were two areas that were
brought up
the first was the president said that
when he shut down china that he
definitely saved a lot of infections
here in the country and he's absolutely
correct that he made a decision
to shut down travel to china and that
was a good decision
that resulted in the saving of lives and
the saving of infections
the issue with the mask is that when we
in the beginning and i'll say it now for
the multiple time i'll try to do it
quickly back in february march when
there were very
few infections in this country there was
a
shortage of masks for the healthcare
providers that needed it
number one we did not want to all of a
sudden
hoard masks and take it away from the
people
who are preparing for the onslaught of
cases
number two the data of the efficacy
of masks were not as clear then
subsequently
studies have come out and experienced
from other countries have made it very
clear
that masks are effective number three
we found out that cotton cloth coverings
were just as good as the surgical mask
and so what was taken off the table
was the shortage there's no longer a
shortage of masks
number one number two the data that show
that mass
works are now very very clear and number
three
when we realized a very important
epidemiological fact
that 40 to 45 percent of the infections
are without symptoms people have no
symptoms so they don't know they're
infected
and modeling shows that a substantial
proportion of transmissions
occur from person who is asymptomatic
and doesn't know they're infected to an
uninfected person
therefore everyone should assume that
you might be infected
therefore we went from saying we really
shouldn't be doing masks
to absolutely people should be wearing
masks
so that gets distorted because we acted
according to the situation at the time
early on it wasn't a situation based on
our knowledge that would have mandated
or given us a strong indication for
masks
right now let there be no confusion
by anybody you should be wearing a mask
keeping distance avoiding crowds
doing things outdoor more than indoor
and washing your hands
i cannot be more clear than that
so how did you feel when the president
sort of made fun of
uh vice president biden
for wearing a big mask
you know i can't comment on that stephen
i just don't want to go there about
critiquing
the president of the united states
okay well we have one more audience
question i want to finish out on it's a
little different spin there
um oscar weinfertner asks what is a
belief that you hold
that many others don't appreciate yet
uh you know the belief that i hold that
if we pull together as a nation
in a unified way to address
this outbreak by adhering to the prudent
and careful public health principles
that will allow us
to continue to open up the economy
and not shut down we're saying
not shut down but continue to open up
the economy
in a careful prudent way that this
outbreak will end we will get a vaccine
i spoke about that a few moments ago and
if we combine
a vaccine with prudent public health
measures
we can put this outbreak behind us and
that's the reason why
we should not despair because despair
makes you throw your hands up and say
it doesn't matter what i do what's going
to happen is going to happen
that is incorrect it does matter
what we do and if we do it for a while
longer
we will look behind us and the outbreak
will be behind us
not among us well i
certainly hope you're right and i thank
you again for
spending your time with us i know you're
a very busy guy
um stay safe thank you very much steven
good to be with you
i am andy greenberg i'm a senior writer
with wired and i cover cyber security
and after that
really excellent last interview with dr
anthony falci
our next panel is going to talk about a
kind of pandemic
within the pandemic asperger speak since
since the spring since this pandemic
began there has been a kind of uh
cyber crime wave a group of bad actors
online has taken advantage
of the desperation surrounding this kova
19 crisis
and use that desperation to launch all
manner of fraud even target medical
facilities and
one group um known as the cyber threat
intelligence
league has kind of heard the call for a
new
group of researchers that respond to
these threats um
and we have with us today um three
members of that group
um owad zaidenberg is the founder of the
cti
league we also have with nate warfield
who is a
security researcher at microsoft and
mark rogers a vp of cyber security at
octa
and nate uh and mark are both founding
members of this group as well now i want
to let
oads take the lead and tell us what is
the cti league and what is your kind of
origin story briefly of this group of
cyber superheroes
thank you andy the cti league is a
global community aspire to protect
the medical sector and the life-saving
organization
worldwide to create a safer cyberspace
for them
earlier this year around february i
started to notice
more and more threat actors leveraging
the corona
as a method as a social engineering
method where they're trying to attack
multiple actors worldwide back then
the virus was an unknown violence from
china and i didn't pay attention
much the values but then when it became
a world crisis i was really afraid of
the scenario
of monochrome and i really afraid that
this scenario will repeat itself
around march i remember a long night
drive that i took from a dental detail
with my family it was the night before
israel entered
its first lockdown and i said i have to
do something because
now it's a little threat now if any
ransomware group
would attack in hospital it's going to
end with
people that is going to die so i
started to think about this community
then
one day after i saw the attack against
the second
biggest hospital in the czech republic
that was the trigger for me
to stop sitting on the fence and start
doing
something you know the chronovirus is a
war but there are people around the
world
trying to leverage the crisis to gain
some profit
whether they are private or they are
state sponsored
and they want to do harm for people
the equilibrium is very clear if an
hospital need to fight ransomware and
pay more money
on fighting cyber cyber security and
cyber attack
it means that they pay less money for
ventilators
or corona departments i sent a message
from
nate wolfe that is here with us
and i said hey i thought in the last few
days about
a community a slack channel where you
can collaborate we can share data
worldwide and say hey we are here for
you
if you are in medical facilities no
matter where
we are here for you to protect you we
want to reduce the level of threat to
you
we want to neutralize cyber threats
looking to harm you
in this most sensitive time for the
medical sector
or to leverage the current crisis to
gain some profit with scans
on the darkness for example together
with mark
and chris myers that is not with us we
created
the first global community ever that
inspired
to protect these organizations at the
first month
we crossed the 1 000 members of the
league and currently we are in the
process of
founding the city elite as an
organization
that protect for the long term this
as we keep growing we understood this is
a real
threat there are thousands of
vulnerabilities in the networks
of this organization and someone need to
supply the services
from the initial part of prevention the
attack supporting them in mitigation of
attack
and then neutralizing with law
enforcement organization
worldwide to neutralize these threats i
really happy that
in the city there are more than 1500
members
worldwide for more than 80 countries we
cause
barriers and sales over the industry
and prove that we can be a community
effective community
they're doing some good in this
sensitive and crisis time
well speaking about some very specific
cyber attacks just in the last
few days we saw this ransomware attack
hit
universal health services this network
of 400 medical facilities across the
united states with 90 000 employees
has been paralyzed by this cyber attack
last week we saw german prosecutors say
that they're going to
go after hackers on actual murder
charges for the first time
for a ransomware attack that caused the
death of a woman
in dusseldorf um you guys have told me
that you don't want to talk about
specific victims which is understandable
there are sensitivities there and this
kind of work
but i was hoping that you could speak
about a kind of like um
like what are the sorts of threats that
you have dealt with how have you dealt
with them what are the kind of greatest
hits of the cti league
maybe that's the question for for nate
or mark if you want to jump in
sure i can jump in um one of the things
that i was most proud about
that we did back in june um there is a
vulnerability
that came out for a piece of network
equipment that runs
along a lot of the hospitals and bank
networks it's very expensive very
mission critical
so myself and a bunch of other members
of the cti league
we saw this come out in i think it was a
tuesday
i was right before the fourth of july
weekend so we just jumped onto it
we spent we have i think about eight of
us worked the entire fourth of july
weekend
uh probably ruining a few barbecues for
those in the united states that were
looking to shoot off fireworks but
by the end of that weekend we managed to
notify about three or four dozen
different hospitals and said hey you've
got a
device that's out there that can very
quickly be turned into a pivot point to
deploy ransomware inside your network um
it was a sort of a similar
category of vulnerability as was used
against the travel x um
credit card network back in december of
2019 so
it was a good feeling knowing that we
we'd gotten the word out to a few folks
and we did see attacks quite literally
started i think it was the sunday or the
monday of that weekend
um so it was uh minutes counted in this
instance and i think we were we were
able to do a really good job
yeah if i can build on i was gonna say
if i could build on what nate said
um we're also seeing attacks across
the entire spectrum i mean it's almost
fair to say that this is a
cyber pandemic because the bad guys
um criminal actors have always exploited
big events
and there is no bigger event than a
global pandemic
and so they're leveraging every aspect
of this that they can
they're sending out documents they're
sending out phishing emails they're
sending out
tailored malware and we see everything
from ridiculously simple
emails with no attachments that just try
to coerce people
through highly sophisticated pieces of
malware with multiple chains of
exploitation to try
and compromise infrastructure it's it's
all going on and
it kind of makes it difficult as a a
defense team because
where do you spend your time in
resources and so we've had to subdivide
into
quite a large number of groups to tackle
all of these different
issues which are then themselves
exacerbated by the fact that
because everybody's at home you don't
have the normal protections that you
would have
from being inside a company you can't go
to your it team or your security team
as easily and triaging a laptop that's
been infected
is now exponentially harder
yeah i mean at the beginning of this
pandemic i remember seeing you quoted
mark as saying that
you saw a level of fishing you would
never seen before uh and
as this as cover 19 becomes less of a
kind of news item and more of just a
basic fact of life has that tailed off
are we still seeing that same
level of kobe 19 related cyber crime
it's still still pretty much there um
whether or not it's growing i i can't
say i mean i think it's
it's probably it's holding steady but
there's nothing new about this
if you dial back to any major event like
for example
if you look back at the sochi olympics
you'll see that there was a massive
fishing campaign
or series of fishing campaigns
associated with that because
bad guys recognize that wherever there's
an absence of information or whether
there's an
interesting fact that people might want
to get
what they do is they use that as a lure
to try and pull in people they
send documents that allege to fill the
gap or that try to
tempt people with information they might
be missing and they go after it and so
as long as the
need for information is out there the
bad guys will be exploiting it
well um as this threat evolves and
um hopefully as kova 19 no longer
becomes that lure
i wanted to give each of you just a
chance very briefly because we're
running out of time here
to talk about what do you what do you
think is the next big threat what is the
thing that keeps each of you
up at night with your kind of like very
unique visibility into all these very
dangerous phenomena
i'll go ahead and start um i think what
keeps me awake at night is after
25 30 years of infosec it doesn't seem
like the problem is uh really getting
any better
um i mean we've made some great advances
in system security and endpoint security
um you know from when i started in this
in the late 90s to what we have today
like the ability to
to catch people has improved drastically
the problem is we're still seeing
vulnerabilities that
are quite literally like 90 zero
vulnerabilities um
that coupled with the ease at which
attackers are sort of leveraging some of
the
defensive tool sets that we use to you
know ascertain security for a corporate
network
these are quickly getting spun around
and used by attackers so the bar
has been raised for defenders and one
side the attackers are using some of
these same tools to raise their own bar
and make their like total career return
on investment for the malware they have
to develop is
is much better when they can just use
commodity tools
um and that's we always feel one step
behind the eight ball and that's that's
what keeps me awake at night
oh what do you want to do please mark go
ahead
okay sorry i was gonna say it's what
keeps me awake at night it's
similar to what nate said is i feel like
we spend too much time focusing on
the highly specific so we've built some
great defenses in very specific areas
we're evolving things like identity at a
furious rate
um but at the same time we've got
companies that aren't able to apply
patches
that don't have the resources to do it
and the biggest one that worries me is
that
we still don't have good cyber security
or even cyber
training in our schools and so kids are
coming out of
uh of high school without the necessary
knowledge and skills
to adequately identify and protect
themselves against this threat
so essentially we're releasing a new
generation of victims each time we push
it out
if we instead taught our kids to
recognize things like phishing attacks
taught our kids about some of the
dangers on the internet we would not
only make them safer
but we'd make our nations safer
well oh since we're running out of time
can i just i want to give you the chance
to have the last word and say what
you're
maybe most worried about but also i
wanted to ask a more general question if
you could maybe
answer this as well can the cti league
continue
once this crisis is over you know
there's always
been this kind of siloing of threat
intelligence a competition among
researchers to be the first to find
something
when the pandemic is over can the cti
lead continue to be this kind of kumbaya
um you know cooperative movements
so that's exactly what i wanted to
answer as i said before we're in process
of funding the league
the cti league is a non-profit
organization that would be able to
supply
their assistance for the medical sector
and life-saving organization
for the long term you know when we
created league
we really focus on corona crisis
related um attacks and we really focused
on
protecting hospitals when we continued
to grow
we saw more and more attacks that we
need to handle with
we started with the hospitals but when
but then we expand ourselves
to the life-saving organization for
example the emergency sector
now we want to keep the protection that
we're going to offer because
they are highly vulnerable and nobody in
the world
protected them before the way we wish to
do
global and community to rely on the
community to walk
side by side with people that i am as an
israeli
can't even visit the country and to work
together as one unit
to protect them so what keep me up
at night and as wire25 for me can't
hecular
what american night is working on
funding the cti league as an
organization that can supply his
assistance for the long term to reduce
the level of threat
to these organizations to neutralize
cyber trades
both looking to harm the medical sector
and the life-saving organization
or to exploit the current covenant and
pandemic
to support the law enforcement
organization that we have amazing
collaborations with them
worldwide against threats that are a
danger for the public safety
and be ready for the next events for
example
mark told uh max spoke about the olympic
games we saw what happened
two years ago in the olympic games and
this is the event
that all the world participate in the
city would
have a intervention team that is ready
for this event and we will continue to
expand ourselves
to protect more organization worldwide
foreign only to do some good in the
world
well i wish you luck in that very
important mission
um nate's mark thank you very much for
joining us thank you for your excellent
work
thanks for having us
hey everyone my name is lily hain newman
i'm a security reporter with wired
thank you for joining us i'm here with
matty stone
she's a security researcher at google's
project xero
and she studies bugs in software
vulnerabilities flaws in software
that are actively being exploited or
sort of weaponized by hackers
out in the world hi maddie how you doing
hey lily i'm doing well
so i think the first thing we need to
talk about in order to
understand what you work on and where
you work at project zero
is to talk about what is a zero-day
vulnerability this is a phrase that
people may have heard
but it can be kind of confusing so a
zero-day vulnerability
is one of those vulnerabilities or
issues
in software that the defenders
don't yet know about unless it's not
fixed there's nothing
in place to prevent it being exploited
by people who want to attack
or cause harm and so for example like
you might get
updates on your phone or microsoft or
windows
any of those things that say hey take a
new security update
um and they usually if you go and read
and tell the notes it tells you all the
vulnerabilities they're fixing that
month prior to those being fixed
they're generally considered zero days
because they're not fixed and people
didn't know to watch out for them
so they're not the sort of mass
exploited types of things they're not
the spam you're getting into
um your email boxes all the time they're
really
targeted sophisticated types of attacks
because it takes a lot of expertise to
find them
um and to exploit them so they're
usually only used to target
you know high-profile um
highly valuable targets such as
political dissidence
uh human rights activists journalists
things like that
so zero day vulnerabilities they're very
uh
valuable to attackers or that you know
they're trying to keep them secret
for this reason you're saying it's not
about targeting everyone it's about
keeping it to yourself so you can use it
when you want it
and one other thing i wanted to say when
you were talking about uh
you know hearing about patches that come
out or software updates that come out
uh those are things that aren't zero
days as you were saying
because zero days are bugs that
defenders have had
zero days to fix right
so exactly that's that timing
yep so it's only before there's no fix
there's not knowledge of them things
like that
right so why does google
have project zero you know there's these
vulnerabilities out there
there's already companies trying to find
bugs in their own
software right like why do we need
another group
that's doing this watch out or look out
for more vulnerabilities
um well to start project zero was formed
back in 2014
and it really came from google's drive
for it was also that
you know chrome and this other software
runs
on other platforms and
insecurities in things such as chrome
running on windows or chrome
running on iphone or flash that runs on
websites that you display in chrome
those vulnerabilities then affected
chrome users and so
project zero was formed to help find and
fix the vulnerabilities and all this
other client
software um and we do it for chrome and
android as well
um and other google products to fix that
because
inherently all of these things we use on
computers and phones
work together so there can only be as
secure as the other
things you're using or running to and
from that point
then we've continued to grow and push
and try to push
new sort of standards for information
security such as when the team was
started
um there was not a deadline
or sort of the expectation that vendors
you know the people writing
selling the software or hardware would
actually
fix vulnerabilities if an external
person worked or reported it to them
and so now there's this
general convention that you report it
and 90 days later you can
you as an external reporter a researcher
of the vulnerability can go public with
it
so it puts this emphasis of the
developers of
you should probably patch this and help
protect your users and fix the
vulnerability
because otherwise 90 days later it's
going to go public and you're going to
have to explain
oh yeah we decided not to fix this
you'll are all still
um at risk right and project zero
really along with other groups but
projects are really you know took a
strong
stand on wanting to push that urgency
right about people fixing things once
they're found
um in terms of your work which sort of
goes this extra step to say
okay we're finding a lot of things but
what about things we
know are being actively exploited by
attackers
why is it important to study those bugs
in particular
along with all the other great work
project zero does
yeah so as a whole the majority of our
team is focusing and putting themselves
in the hat of an attacker they're
looking for vulnerabilities in any sort
of client-facing side software
ios android chrome microsoft
safari firefox etc anything that's
really on the user versus a company side
um whereas my job is to then focus on
what are the attackers actually using
against people
and the reason for that is that we
always want to make sure that our
research
and our ability to try and act and
compete
with the attackers is based in the
reality of what they're actually doing
and what they care about so sometimes in
the industry we use this term of
private state of the art versus public
state of the art meaning
the attackers in the private state of
art they know what their actual state of
the art is
what challenges they're facing what
tools they have what
expertise they have but we on the
defender side
really only know what's public and have
to try and figure out what the attackers
are doing
so any time an attacker zero day exploit
is found and detected that's their
failure case
they did not intend for it to be
discovered and for us to know what
they're doing
so we capitalize on that learning as
much as we can about
what is the vulnerability um they're
actually exploiting
and how might they have found at what
type of tools were they using
what type of exploitation methodologies
they were using
um and different things like that
because then we can take that knowledge
and apply it for more systemic fixes in
the software
rather than just a single bug because
we're just fixing each single
vulnerability as we find it it's a lot
of
whack-a-mole and the attackers only have
to find one vulnerability to have a
successful exploit but we as defenders
have to defend them all
so a better return on investment is
really studying it and figuring out
okay they know about this exploit method
and they're using it
can we break this exploit methodology as
a whole
can we fix a vulnerability class as a
whole
instead of that single vulnerability
that we now know um they found
i like what you've said in the past that
you
don't want these cyber weapons or these
exploit tools to be democratized you
know that your work is about trying to
sort of nip things in the bud just as
you're describing
uh we have one really quick uh
viewer question from howard fox
he asked is it a hindrance or a help to
work within a large
matrix organization with billions of
users so
does it you know does google scale and
reach help
or hinder your research um for my
research
here on project zero i think in general
um
it helps because one um
google has actually been very good at
letting us act as external researchers
we are able to report to google and
chrome with
the exact same manner the exact same
deadlines
um not always the best public press
in the same way that we do for external
companies
but then at the same time we have access
to a lot of resources like
we have plenty of access to technology
to build new
tools to try and find vulnerabilities to
build new
um research new detection methods for
how might we try and find new
vulnerabilities
and you know i'm not really making
google any money
yet they still pay my salary and allow
me to do this
research that is not always going to be
successful and has
a risk so i think overall it's a net
benefit since you know i have a job and
get to do this work i care about
yeah well thank you so much for joining
us maddie uh
we hope google keeps paying you and
please keep burning zero days
thanks lily
hey everyone my name is lily hey newman
can't get rid of me that easily i'm a
security reporter with wired
thanks for being here i'm here with ben
adida he's the executive director of
voting works
and they're a non-profit developer of
open source voting machines
and audit software so this is the guy we
all really want to talk to today how you
doing ben
i'm doing really well how about you lily
i'm good thanks
so you all are developing uh
open source voting machines why is that
important
why is that different what's going on
with voting machines right now
yeah i think the really important thing
is to start with why do we even need
voting machines in the u.s
why can't we just have a piece of paper
circle our candidate
put it in the box at the end of the day
we make some piles we count them
done right there's two big reasons for
that that are really
yeah there's two big reasons for that
that are really important to highlight
the first one is that um you need
uh we need to count ballots in the us
that are particularly complex
whereas in france for example you might
vote on one contest
in the u.s you vote on 20 40 sometimes
as many as 90.
and for that we need computers for speed
and accuracy
humans just can't do the job as fast or
as
accurately and then the second reason so
we need equipment to
count ballots and then we also need
equipment to help
many millions of voters produce their
paper ballot because
many millions of voters can't read ten
point font or fill out tiny bubbles
and that's another area where we need
voting equipment
so you asked you know what does voting
works do
um well who makes these machines right
these are the foundation of democracy
they're the
the operating system of democracy voting
works
is the only non-profit election
equipment maker
and we think that elections are the
foundation of democracy
and that foundation should be publicly
owned it's for us a question of trust
and transparency
so what are some other uh
efforts this year or things that are
going to be different
in the 2020 election uh that are sort of
other movements
in this direction of uh verifiability
and accountability i think the most
important election security story of
is not the one you're thinking of it's
risk limiting audits
and i know that's a mouthful but i want
to explain it because it is a giant
success of election security and we
should be talking
about it more and that is i just
mentioned we need computers to tabulate
our votes right we need that for
security
sorry we need it for accuracy and speed
but should we really trust the computer
to tell us who won the election and of
course the answer is no we need to audit
it in some way
and we want the speed and accuracy of
computers and we want the trust and
verifiability
of a multi-partisan group of humans
checking individual ballots
risk limiting audits square that circle
they allowed us to get both
the computers do the tabulation so
quickly and accurately
and then humans get together and through
a rigorous statistical method
look at a small sample of those ballots
to confirm the work
of the tabulators a state can typically
do this in one or two days
so before results are certified and
get a much higher level of uh
security and integrity for that election
the the the crazy thing about risk
learning audits is we haven't done this
kind of rigorous statistical
stuff and we haven't
we never did it until 2017 that's the
first time that happened
which means this election 2020 is the
first time we're running this kind of
rigorous statistical audit
in a presidential election in the u.s
and the wonderful news is
that we're expect to see five to eight
states this year
uh up from zero four years ago do this
kind of rigorous statistical audit
and uh voting works is really really
proud to be
uh making the software that's going to
run
almost all those audits for states this
year
yeah well up from zero it's a really
impressive number and
it sounds like it's going to be a big
contribution
in this election when there's so much
going on
we could say so on that note
uh you know i think we should talk about
vote by mail a little bit
um you know we're just
hearing so much uh conflicting
information about vote by mail uh
and absentee by mail voting and all
these different phrases
uh including uh in the presidential
debate
last night uh can you talk a little bit
about fraud in
vote by mail what what's the concern
there
so the bottom line is that if you talk
to election security experts
including me but not just including me
vote by mail fraud is simply not a major
concern
if you look at the data it happens
occasionally
it usually gets caught it doesn't happen
at the scale that would ever come close
to impacting
the outcome of an election and so it's
this
this discussion of vote by mail fraud is
much ado about nothing
i think the more important conversation
about vote by mail
is how kovid has obviously forced states
to significantly
step up their game on vote by mail and
for many states it's a pretty
significant chance a significant change
and that change means we're going to see
some hiccups right expect to see some
hiccups around this
just like you're seeing hiccups in every
other aspect of your life around covet
19.
but the thing to remember is the
election officials around the country
from both parties
are working so incredibly hard to make
this work they're the true heroes here
uh just remember that when you're
criticizing elections or how they're run
like uh they're your friends they're
your neighbors they're
they're helping democracy and they're
working seven days a week
long days to make this work there will
be some small hiccups
but vote by mail is safe if that's how
you want to vote request your ballot
vote at home send it in if you prefer to
drop it off if your state allows that go
ahead and drop it off
do it as early as you can that will help
your election officials
you know process all the ballots in
states where they're allowed to process
them early
that's how what you can do to help and
if you want to vote in person
do that too sorry don't do that too do
that
or vote by mail don't do both and
come in vote wear a mask socially
distance follow the instructions
make sure your voice is heard don't
worry about vote by mail fraud it's not
a significant concern
and to your point about all the hard
work that election officials
put in what if and when
there's a delay in getting results uh
on election day and after election day
what should we assume
is happening during that time you know
is that
all election officials just like forging
all the ballots and going on vacation
or what's going to be happening in those
weeks
yeah first of all election officials
aren't going to be going on vacation
until probably late december between all
the work they're doing because what
they're going to do after election day
is what they've done
every year which is canvas make sure
they got all the ballots make sure all
the ballots are counted make sure that
if there's any close election they
follow
any auditing procedures they have for
some of the states they're going to be
running those risk limiting audits we
talked about
and so uh the thing to understand is
while we are accustomed
to election results declared on election
night although
as we know it's not not all the time
right election 2000 was one
recent example where the result wasn't
known on election night
uh the official results have never been
known
until three weeks after the election the
time it takes to make sure all the
ballots are counted
including military ballots that
sometimes come in a little bit later
right but also including vote by mail
ballots that are coming in a couple days
after the election
in states where you're allowed to send
them up until the day of the election
these are valid votes and we should
count them all and it might take a few
days
and because there's so much more vote by
mail this year
uh there might be enough unknown on
election night because those ballots are
still coming in and being counted
that maybe we won't declare a winner on
election night and that's okay
that's not any different than anything
we've ever done before
it's just we have a little bit more vote
by mail and so getting those votes
counted will take a few more days
and that's okay but your election
officials are not going to be on
vacation
for a while they got work to do yeah
definitely not
my last question for you ben is you know
why
is misinformation or all this confusion
about the
voting process so problematic and why is
it so important for us to talk about
so two days ago it's really a great
question it's a really important
question
two days ago the fbi and the department
of homeland security
issued a warning about election security
and integrity
and it wasn't about hacked voting
machines and it wasn't about vote by
mail
it was specifically about this
information that reduces
people's trust in election integrity and
the reason that's important is because
democracy only works if we believe in it
you have to run an election well but if
the people don't believe
in the outcome of an election it's a
problem and so the biggest attack and
the biggest concern i have this year
is not around any of this vote by mail
fraud that isn't the problem
hacked voting machines which we should
be worried about but also there's no
evidence that's happening
the biggest concern i have is that a lot
of well-meaning folks out there
who care about democracy are going to
see an alarmist story on their twitter
feed
or in their facebook feed or i don't
think they happen on instagram but maybe
on instagram too
and they're going to say i need to tell
my friends about this this is important
i'm going to retweet or share and in the
process
become an unwitting participant in this
misinformation game
of reducing people's trust in an
election outcome
please register to vote vote
vote early if you can but don't amplify
messages
that reduce people's trust in elections
because if you do
if we lose faith in democracy we lose
democracy
all right it's a chilling warning thank
you so much for joining us ben
thanks lily great to chat
hello my name is rhett elaine i'm an
associate professor of physics
at southeastern louisiana university and
a frequent contributor to wired
i'm here today with dr lisa picariello
an assistant professor of mathematics at
mit
where she specializes in the field of
topology her research focuses
on the interaction between four foot
four manifold topology
and not theory hi lisa how are you doing
hi i'm great it's nice to talk to you
great
good thanks for being here so let's
start off with a question
about maybe you've answered this quite a
few times in your recent years but what
would you say is the difference between
not theory
and topology
yeah so not theory is a study of knots
so
uh what's it not a knot is what you get
if you go down in the basement and you
find your extension cord
and uh it's probably like a disaster if
it's been down there for a while and
that's that's fine
uh just plug the ends together so now
it's a disaster but it's also a circle
that's a and in that theory we study
things like if you take yours and your
best friend takes theirs
uh is it possible without unplugging the
ends
to make your knot look exactly like your
friend's knot
so that's what not theory cares about in
topology
we care about spaces that are locally
really boring
so a boring space is something like a
line that's a one-dimensional space or a
piece of paper that's two-dimensional or
like the room you're sitting in which is
three-dimensional
so those spaces are boring and we pay
attention to spaces that are locally
boring
but globally more interesting so
if you looked at for example the skin on
an orange
and that's a space that i think of as
two-dimensional because if you zoom
way in it looks flat like a piece of
paper you can't really tell it's curved
but globally something more interesting
is going on
uh so that's what topology studies
okay so i know that really we want to
talk about this conway problem this
conway knot
and i in order to understand that we
have to people talk about the term
sliceness of a knot so can you give an
explanation of a sliceness of a knot
yeah so first let me tell you what it
means for a knot to bound a disc
in three dimensions um so
let's suppose you took a tablecloth a
round tablecloth
and maybe it has a lace border on it so
that lace border that's going to be a
knot right it's like a circle sitting in
three-dimensional space that's what a
knot is
and when the tablecloth's on the table
it's easy to see
that that circle looks kind of boring it
bounds a disc it's the boundary of this
tablecloth
okay so that's a boring knot and it
bounced a disc in three space
now let's suppose dinner's over and you
crumple up the tablecloth and you throw
in the hamper
and then you use your x-ray vision to
look at the hamper and look
just at the lace um it's gonna look
very messy um it's no longer just like a
boring circle it looks
crazy uh but i claimed that that knot it
still
bounds the disc in three-dimensional
space because it's still balanced
the tablecloth like the tablecloth is in
the hamper
so a question you can ask is does it not
bound to disk in three dimensional space
and that's maybe the first question of
not theory
and that's not sliceness sliceness is
whether or not bounce a disk in
four dimensional space so same question
but now i'm asking
can you find a tablecloth that you're
not at the boundary of but i'm gonna let
that tablecloth
use a little bit of extra space if it
needs to
so not just in three dimensions as main
dimensions as you want are we
defining this to just steal realistic
three dimensions
of four dimensions okay so but you can
see
um no yeah but it won't be very
interesting
now let me point out i know that this is
complicated stuff and you're trying to
describe these very complicated ideas in
two three-minute segments and that is
really tough it's sort of like
uh haiku right um but but with that in
mind
you are known for solving this conway
not problem so could you give an
explanation of the conway knot problem
sure um so the conway knot is
this not that john conway sort of jumped
up and it's got some funny properties
and and the problem is uh is it slice
yes or no
and then and then you figure that out
yeah it's not slice
okay so what what what was a
big insight that allowed you to solve
this problem that no one had solved it's
a decades-old problem
so what was the the change that made you
able to solve that problem
um so i study these four-dimensional
spaces that are related to
a knot in fact like i'm more of a
topologist than an authorist so i'm
interested in spaces
um but i but i knew this fact other
people knew this fact too
which is that if you have two different
knots that produce the same
four-dimensional space
then they're either both slice or
they're both not slice
um so people want to know if the conway
knot is slice or not but for whatever
reason the conway knot is sort of
pathologically difficult to work with
so the the insight of my work is that
well i won't work with the conway knot
because it's hard
i'll build another knot that shares the
same space as it and try to study the
other knot
if i can show that now it's not slice
then the conway knot can't be sliced
so i mean we don't have a bunch of time
left i want to get to the really
important question that i want to talk
about
and that this is really abstract stuff
but do you think
that in in both high school and in
college and graduate school that
that abstract math should be part of
everyone's education or should just
certain people study
abstract math ah that's a great question
um well i think that
no not everybody should study abstract
math it's sort of like studying
literature
like if you love it then you should
study it but it's not important that
everybody in the world
uh be able to prove that route 2 is
irrational
um however man do you think that
everyone
has some understanding of the basic
ideas though or do you think
they shouldn't even look at it
well i think what's important is
that is it maybe that people get some
idea of what abstract math is all about
because
the math that's currently taught in
schools is very computational
and you you do a lot of routines you
take a derivative or you
uh multiply fractions and that's not
what mathematicians do at all what we
really do is we try to make
careful rigorous arguments about
straightforward objects and i think it
is a really different flavor
than the math you learn in even in high
school
i didn't learn that abstract math was
like that until college
and most people like they're done with
math by college they don't want any more
of that
so i think it would be good if we could
give a flavor of what being
mathematician is all about
a bit earlier in our education
yeah i think that's a probably a good
idea too so well
lisa thank you very much for joining me
and having a discussion about math i
really enjoyed it
and it was great to have you on thanks
hey everybody welcome my name is alan
henry i'm the service editor here at
wired
i am happily joined by patrice peck aka
speak patrice
accomplished journalist with over a
decade of experience in elevating and
amplifying
underrepresented and under-reported
stories uh her work has been published
in the new york times in buzzfeed ebony
vogue
l the list goes on but today we're here
to talk to her about her incredibly
important newsletter
coronavirus news for black folks which
aims to speak directly to the black
community
a community already disproportionately
affected by the pandemic
but with information and advice that we
can't uh get in traditional media
patrice thanks for being here
thanks for having me of course uh so
let's start with a pretty standard
question uh what inspired you
to start the coronavirus for black folks
at chrono invites news for black folks
newsletter
sure so my back my educational
background is in um
last studies i got my undergraduate
degree in black studies at amherst
college and i'm also
a black person i have the lived
experience um
and so in early i want to say late
february that's when i
started to really follow and track any
news that was coming about about the
coronavirus
and once i realized that people
with pre-existing medical conditions
were more likely
um or at higher risk to suffer severe
illness from
coronavirus that's when i realized okay
this virus is going to
really devas excuse me devastate the
black community because
because of anti-black systemic racism
there is an overwhelming amount of
pre-sex pre-existing medical conditions
in the black community
um and i also realized just as a
journalist
that because a lot of publications
within the black press um
have shuttered or folded or downsized
drastically again because of
systemic racism and just the shifting of
the media landscape in general
i just knew that we needed like a hug
for any news about the chronovirus as it
relates directly
to black people
yeah so and you mentioned the shuttering
of a lot of
traditional black media and black press
and and in your newsletter you mentioned
that you wanted to fill some of those
gaps in coverage that
traditional media outlets have and those
blind spots that
they traditionally take when they cover
underrepresented communities
what do you think some of those blind
spots are why do you think they have
those gaps in coverage
hmm i honestly
that's a great question oh broad i mean
there's so many gaps
because for example the first sort of
original piece that i did
for the newsletter was an interview
series called essential in black because
i noticed so
much of the media's narrative around
essential workers
at the start of the pandemic was
focusing a lot on
white nurses and doctors and
as we soon learned um a large percentage
of essential workers are
women but especially black and brown
women
and so my series um focused specifically
on
black essential workers so i spoke with
um a young black security guard who
worked at a homeless prevention center i
spoke
with a pregnant woman who worked at um
as a hospital administrator um
and so you know i i wanted to
show to my audience that you know your
voice and your story
during this pandemic does matter
especially again because
of how we are being disproportionately
impacted
that that leads me to a good point uh so
just last week
the president stood in front of a rally
and said
that the coronavirus affects
basically nobody and that was happened
to be the same day or the day before we
essentially crossed that grim milestone
that 200 000 americans had died
what do you think contributes to this
disparity between some people thinking
that it affects nobody
and then other people knowing that it's
actually a really really big deal
hmm i think it
again another very great broad question
i think it just goes
back to sort of
what your experience is living in this
country living in america
and what realities you face
right if you consistently experience
and witness systemic racism
in various points of your life
throughout your entire life
it's going to be more likely that you're
willing to accept
you know inequities and systemic racism
and oppression and white supremacy and
all those being very real
um but honestly
if if again in the black community and
you know in latino community indigenous
communities
you'll speak to someone and they know at
least
a handful of people who've been infected
by the coronavirus or have died from the
coronavirus or
whose family member is an essential
worker
like my mother is um a nurse
um just as there are a lot of you know
black caribbean
um immigrants who work in the medical
profession no
in the profession my mother is one um
i mean it's it just goes back to i think
empathy and really understanding
that you know there are intersectional
identities
and you know if if
if you've never been one of those
disenfranchised
you know within one of those
disenfranchised communities
you know there's there's just that gap
right so i have a question from a viewer
andrew martin
um he asks how do you stay resilient
in tumultuous times like 2020 what
brings you joy what helps you keep going
hmm good question
um i stay resilient number one
i know number one um i go to therapy
um i really advocate therapy um
especially to people from
disenfranchised communities
um i recent a few weeks or months ago i
did an article from new york times
called self-care for black journalists
and one of the journalists told me about
the open path collective
which operates on like a sliding pay
range
so it's affordable and you could also
select um
your to you could search for a therapist
by ethnicity or race which is also
very crucial sometimes because someone
who's gonna understand
you know different nuances in terms of
your identity and and how
you experience um the world but i would
also want to add
you know i'm a big watcher of tv and i
i've been watching steven universe um
just things that make me
feel good because even though i feel
guilty when i'm not working
which is something again i'm working on
in therapy
i just don't know what use i'm going to
be
as a journalist um and as a member of my
k
of my community if i am burnt out
and angry and frustrated um
which you know i those are all valid
feelings
um but they don't necessarily
they're not they don't feel good to me
right yeah no therapy and therapy and tv
good good tips i'm here for both of
those
and they always say you're no good to
the movement if you're burned out to
move right
so that is also true uh patrice thank
you so much
thank you so much for your time thank
you for joining me um and
thanks yeah i hope you're able to
subscribe to your newsletter because
it's super important
yes thanks
hi i'm megan multani staff science
writer here at wired
thank you for joining us for this year's
wired25
we're really happy to have with us here
avi schiffman avi is a 17 year old
senior
at mercer island high school outside of
seattle and the winner of this year's
webby person of the year award back in
january he single-handedly built
one of the very first global coronavirus
tracking site which has today attracted
nearly 1.5 billion
unique visitors so we're going to talk
about that and some of the other
projects he's launched since then so avi
thanks for being with us
for sure thank you so much yeah so
you know these days tracking covered
cases is kind of like second nature like
check email check twitter
check urban cases um there's lots of
apps and dashboards to do this but back
in january there wasn't so like what
were you seeing can you take us back to
that time
yeah back when i started this website
there were no other coveted trackers
that i could find i mean
the domain for my website ncof2019 is
you know kind of hard to say and kind of
ridiculous but that was just the
unofficial name for the virus back then
you know the name covet 19 just didn't
exist you know when i started this
website the only way to find
information on the current virus you
know if you wanted the most up-to-date
numbers was to go to
chinese government websites but you know
i don't speak mandarin and you know
they're just not nice to look at on like
a mobile device all these government
websites just
you know if i'm trying to visit it on my
phone i you know i just can't you know
they're make
they're made in like the early 2000s um
and
there's also you know news articles that
come out every once in a while back then
but those are mostly out of date by the
time i read them anyways
and they're not like dynamically
updating or anything like that so i
thought it'd be cool to just make like a
dashboard to track that and that's what
i did in kind of
you know early january so what did that
actually involve like from a programming
standpoint
yeah well i had to make a bunch of web
scrapers which is kind of the same
technology that google uses to
you know like rank different pages and
what i'm able to do then is so let's say
i don't know korea
they have like a korean government
website kind of similar to we have the
cdc you know most countries have that
and then what i'm able to do is
basically download
all the information on that page with
all the html
and they have usually like a table of
numbers but you know it's all in korean
but i'm able to just take that
and you know mix the numbers up and you
know parse it and whatever and add it to
a much larger data set with all the
other countries and i do that for
you know i guess all 195 countries now
and then a bunch of
breakdowns so for the united states it's
another 50 web scrapers
um you know it's a big hassle but you
know it gets the job done
yeah how long did it take you to put
this together
yeah the original version took me maybe
like a a couple days or something like
that i had already made something very
similar for my high school
where i was tracking sports but um
instead of tracking sports i just you
know put the link to
uh you know chinese government websites
instead and was able to just get that
information
um and then you know just reskinned to
basically a sports website i had made
and then
you know it only took me a couple days
to make the first version but you know
i mean every single day for months and
months you know it took you know
there were new countries getting
infected every single day so those are
new web scrapers to make
you know things were changing format
very often so i had to recode a lot of
web scrapers so
you know a lot of manual things i have
to do every single day for months and
months now now it's been pretty stable
as
most countries you know keep the same
format and new york is not making like a
new dashboard every day but
you know back in like march and
everything you know every single day
with something new so
yeah so since then you know it's it's
blown up it's obviously become
this huge thing but you've started to
move on to some other projects i know
that
you've built a site dedicated to writing
resources for black lives matter
protesters and
next project is elections including some
work you're doing with snapchat so what
can you tell us about that
sure yeah i'm making something with
elections that i hope to release
sometime this week it's it's
taken me a while just because you know
i'm not like uh i'm a master of politics
or anything but
you know it's really hard to mix that
kind of stuff unbiased but um i've been
working on a website i think will be
really cool
and that will be out in a couple days
hopefully um
but yeah i mean yeah
what's on the website um are you trying
to address
there i'd say like you know there's all
these things out there
to get people to vote but i feel like
once you actually do want to vote
you know who do you actually vote for i
feel like a lot of people just want to
learn more
about the actual policies of the
candidates that you know that they're
voting for and
you know in a way that makes sense it's
not just some like you know government
thing you know if you go to the campaign
websites of trump or biden you know
it's really hard just to find the
information that you want
and even if you finally do get to some
kind of immigration page on these
candidates pages
you know it's like a couple little
quotes or something like that you can
you can barely see anything you know i
want to be able to see
you know past policies all that kind of
stuff you know things that they've done
with their budget proposals all kinds of
things in just an easy to read way
that doesn't look like a you know boring
government kind of page
so i think will be really cool and i i
think the you know user interface looks
really nice and it'll it'll be a really
cool project
and i think people will like it a lot
and find a lot of good information on
there
are you going to be able to vote in this
year's election i will actually i'll
turn 18
october 26th so i'm pretty excited about
that you know i just barely make the cut
which will be kind of cool yeah i know
that um
you're doing all this on top of your
schoolwork with an eye toward heading to
stanford at some point like what's drawn
you down
to silicon valley sure i mean
there's plenty of colleges i would want
to go to but stanford is definitely
number one just because they have so
many resources for just
you know tech entrepreneurship i mean
there are like classes on how to make
startups and stuff
at stanford and i feel like i just don't
have that you know like my local
community college or something i mean
there's plenty of good
colleges for different things but i
think stanford is just you know they
really have a niche of just
tech entrepreneurship in the whole
silicon valley area there's plenty of
colleges around there too like berkeley
and everything that
you know i will definitely apply to um i
don't know if i'll get into any of them
but
you know nothing's 100 but uh i hope so
just because i mean there's just so many
you know connections and opportunities
and things
that happen in silicon valley that might
not happen if i'm in like you know
florida or something like that yeah just
one final question for you
before we have to go do you think coding
should be a required part of a kid's
education today um you know
that that's a common question and a lot
of people will you know say that
everyone should learn to code i really
don't think that
everyone should learn to code just
because it's a very complicated thing to
learn you need to be able to sit at a
computer for just
you know like eight hours shirt or
something like that i mean i could stay
at my computer if i didn't need to sleep
or eat like i could just stay on there
like indefinitely but a lot of people
just
can't stay on their computer for a long
amount of time and you know you really
need to be able to do that if you're
going to be doing programming i mean it
takes hours and hours but
the actual concept of coding is
something that i think should be taught
in just you know some kind of way i mean
the whole if then statements all that
kind of stuff teaches you to problem
solve in all kinds of different ways i
mean i only spend like one percent of my
time actually typing
you know code on my laptop most of the
time it's just thinking about how you're
going to solve a problem in the most
efficient way
and you know talking to people about how
you would even solve these problems in
the first place
you know there's so many good resources
online to learn how to code
you know you can really learn anything
online from you know underwater basket
weaving to
you know how to code in c sharp or
anything so
yeah yeah well thanks avi thanks for
um showing us that you know there's a
way to solve any problem
if you put your mind to it um and we
hope the rest of you stick around for
more wire 25 after this
sure thank you so much
hi i'm adam rodgers i'm a senior
correspondent at wired thank you for
being with us for wired 25
uh we're really happy to have with us
here audrey tong
the digital minister of taiwan they're a
global voice for open source technology
for
digital democracy the youngest cabinet
minister in taiwanese history
um and they're also part of a government
that has had a
tremendous success in dealing with the
pandemic disease covet 19 partially for
a lot of the
work that they've done so we're going to
talk a little bit about that too
minister thanks for taking time for
doing this sure of course good luck code
time everyone
before we do anything else i want to ask
you to be a little bit of a wired
correspondent for me
um because taiwan has had um 150 cases
of cloven 19 and seven deaths
uh that's point zero three deaths per
hundred thousand people in the
population compared to 66
deaths per 100 000 in the united states
for the cdc
so i want to ask you what is it like
there
being there is everyone wearing masks
are businesses closed or open are
schools open are people in transit
what's
what is it like being in a place that
isn't dealing with the pandemic
the way the united states is yeah we do
have our
max handy as you can see here and
people do wear it if they can't keep a
physical distance
especially in a more closed room
so although there are of course very
large gatherings
such as i don't know tens of thousand
people going to concerts
movies baseball games and so on they do
all wear masks
and there's also thermometers that
portable ones that checks your
temperature when you enter the public
buildings and that's pretty much it
that's the most visible changes you can
see but otherwise life is normal
the response that taiwan was able to
mount was fast involved a lot of masks
involved dealing with people at airports
coming in and out
my understanding is the part of the
thing that enabled all of that is
was data was a national medical records
database
and you worked on attaching mask
distribution to that
how important was that national database
and how important is the kind of open
data and people working with data that
you work on
connected to that the uh idea very early
on
uh is that we need to reach um this kind
of physical vaccine
availability of three quarters that's a
number that's
uh literally like we're all striving for
since
uh around january to finally reaching it
around
early march uh to get three quarters of
population into the habit of wearing
masks and hand sanitation
uh and so because of that we instead of
you know using any sort of top-down
lockdown or takedown mechanisms we
simply relied on the pharmacists
who already had experience dispensing
like recurring prescriptions for the
elderly and so on
a very interesting system where
everybody has the ic card called the
national health insurance card
which is by law only useful for public
service and never for commercial
purposes
and we built the mask dispensing here
so to speak rationing system on top of
that and then
we publish not only as urban data uh
which would
probably mean every one day or every
week update rate
but open api which is every 30 seconds
um updates
all the availability of all the
pharmacies in all the masts
and so uh the end result is that people
queuing in line can refresh on their
phone
and see people queuing before them
actually purchase two or three or nine
nowadays or training for a child
and then keep this whole system honest
and accountable by participatory
auditing essentially
instead of relying on a central database
to do all the auditing if
they notice anything wrong they would
just call this toll-free number 1922
and report whatever they have seen on
the ground so it's also a co-creation
system
do people do something interesting do
anything interesting with the apis was
there
yeah there's more than 140 applications
there's not only the obvious
visualization and chatbots and
voice assistants and so on but there's
also analysis uh
like uh whether it's an even or uneven
distribution
there was a legislator uh in gaul who
worked as
vp of data analytics at foxconn so she
knows something about data
and then she brings this open street map
based
analysis uh to her interpolation in the
parliament uh to the ministry
of health and welfare and said you know
while your map looks like
evenly distributed it's only on kind of
a map distance
but if you take into account the more
rural areas the time they spend on
public transport the actual supply and
demand
actually looks very different and it's
actually not an even distribution
and the administration simply said let's
just later teach us
and then we started working uh with the
open source community and revise our
distribution
uh strategy the very next day and also
introducing pre-ordering
and 24 hours pickups on the convenience
stores to make it more even uh and so of
course mp goes very happy and posted on
her social media saying that yesterday's
interpolation is tomorrow's upgrade
which is i think a pretty good slogan is
that the kind of participatory democracy
that you
have hoped for you've been an advocate
for this long before the pandemic
that sounds like the ideal of what you
meant there was this crisis and and the
access to the data allowed people to
sort of code their own solutions in
in conjunction with the government is
that i mean that sounds great
yeah of course of course and and also i
will add to it in that uh
it it takes a lot of trust from the
government to the citizenry
if we uh do not publish like data in
such a radically transparent and
real-time fashion
uh it will be taken as kind of a
distrust right we're the experts the
citizens knows very little
and so we shouldn't publish anything
unquote but
by publishing the data in real time and
by keep saying essentially legislators
teach us uh or is a great idea or let's
think about it together and so on uh
it's almost like a pygmalion effect
right where uh the more uh citizens uh
receive
such kind of trust messages from the
government the government powers
believes in people
then the more trustworthy actually the
people become when you spoke to my to my
colleague andrew leonard
for the story that we did about you you
you um made an analogy between
building the possibility for this kind
of open data and digital democracy with
taoism
you talked about a poem i think that had
said that you the the usefulness the
useful part of the pod is where there is
no pot and that you had created
something similar i want to kind of get
you to talk about that some more about
how this kind of
relates to a dallas philosophy about
what open data should be and what
democracy should look like does it
relate to that
the full uh chapter i think it's chapter
11 uh
it's uh the use of not uh because like
30 spokes
meet in a hub where the wheel isn't is
where it's useful
hollowed out clay makes a pot where the
pots not
is where it's useful cut doors cut
windows to make a room
where the room isn't there's room for
you so the profit in what is
is in the use of what isn't terms like
ngo non-governmental organizations
npo non-profit organizations um
the use of what is what is
profit-seeking and what is government
is in the use of what isn't is in the
ngos and npos
or as in taiwan we call it the social
sector if the social sector determine
the use
of what isn't stem of the business
sector and the
public sector's infrastructures then
we're in a much better place a much more
resilient society because
everybody can instead of being you know
data literate
they can be data competent uh instead of
just receiving and
understanding media and messages and
narratives
they can be producers of media and
messages
and narratives and that's the idea of
the use of not you worked in silicon
valley
for a while do you do you think that
that has relevance to the kind of
the philosophical approach in silicon
valley the sort of disruptive
entrepreneurship
move fast and break things for profit
motive does it relate to them can
can the people who think about things
that way understand
the structure for democracy that you're
laying out can you imagine them changing
toward that
certainly um i mean the core of the
internet governance
if you followed how ietf works uh which
now they also say that they're built for
its users um which is a very uh
political statement a rfc to make
um and and that is uh first first of all
that's that's governance it is actually
politics and it's good to see its
like admitting like we're a governing
entity uh and also um the idea of rough
consensus running code
um is both of course move fast and break
things because that's permissionless
innovation but there's also a sense of
rough consensus in it meaning that
people need to feel that they can live
with whichever
innovations that's there right uh and so
i think there's
a core in the ietf in the internet
engineering
ideas that as long as you publish um
very quickly your failures as well as
your successes
uh then and then you're fine because
you're basically making the community
learn from your failures and
our musk availability map actually was a
a
big failure for many pharmacists on the
first day of launch which is early
february because they're handing out uh
the cards
uh in exchange of those ic cards
and so they swipe the ic cards quite
slowly
while uh making sure that they uh can
hand out
those uh allocated quotas very quickly
um and so
there's a discrepancy and there's even
some pharmacists that
use such mechanisms just very loudly
announced on the front door
don't trust the app and so it's not like
it's it's utopic
uh the the very uh first time right so
the take a number system the limited
time sales and so on uh invented
by the farmers could be seen as
permissionless innovation certainly not
uh you know forthcomed by the cecc by
the central academic command center
but with such ideas we work with
specific technologists
we improve the automated process and
more importantly we change the api every
thursday to reflect what actually works
in the ground
and so we introduced the time slots for
the map builders to actually show the
pharmacist only in the time that they
open
we introduced a button that each
pharmacist can press and disappear from
the map
and so on and so this idea is that when
the government is willing to understand
the needs of pharmacy provides such a
digital space
for mutual participation then we can
complement each other and win back more
social trust
and that is how the so-called pandemic
fighting national team grow
stronger and stronger i guess i'm trying
to figure out
how to what what the architecture would
be among sort of
the governance of the specific
technology government in general
the people who are building the
technology which in the united states
are very
separate and then the experience that so
many citizens have
of this kind of technology which is in
addition to usefulness and also
convenience
is one of trolling and harassment and
disinformation and sort of politics of
opposition and
what made it possible to build that in
taiwan that would make it possible also
in the united states to have a system
of that kind of trust and youthfulness
what works in taiwan
is basically a paradigm shift that we
see democracy
as a set of technologies and so there's
a lot of room for technologists
to work with democracy and we're not
satisfied with only
say uploading three bits per person
every four years which is called voting
by the way
and we work on increasing the bid rate
and we have framing like this there's
far more room for the
technologist to work with the democracy
proponents and
being a younger democracy of course
we're more willing to experiment but
there's nothing um
preventing the american experiment the
great american experiment from
experimenting with democracy again
that three bits three bits a year just
broke my heart i don't know if you could
see it on screen but sure that's the
only time they ever hear from me is when
i
go say well that that person or that
person i guess that's an interesting
phrase that the description of
democracy is a kind of technology it's a
technology for working the levers of
government right of like
of how do you actually make the
government do what it's supposed to
and you want more responsiveness i
hadn't i haven't thought of that
structure
in that vein we actually had a question
from a viewer too donald staton asks the
question how do we remove
politics from science and technology
thank you for that donald before i ask
you to answer that i want to say it does
sound like you're proposing entirely the
opposite of that that what you're saying
is that
we should be injecting science and
technology into politics and politics
into
science and technology um so how do i
should those be decoupled or should they
be more tightly coupled yeah
in taiwan uh before the sunflower
occupied before 2014
it's true that when people hear about
science and technology they mostly think
about natural science and apply
industrial technologies
including digital technologies on the
other hand social science air science
too
and social technology such as democracy
is
a application of science which is means
that it's technology
it's just bringing technology to where
people are instead of asking
people to conform to technology which
would be disruptive
and the whole idea of the taiwan model
is that we make sure that the
technologies come to where people are
adapt to people's needs and empower
people closest to the pain
to be technologists uh in other words
build competence
not literacy and that is the core of the
k-12 curriculum that's the core of the
broadband as human rights
governing structure and that's at the
core also of our response system of the
cecc
because you see when cecc um sees cases
and i'll use one example to illustrate
this where one
nightclub employee was diagnosed with
copenhagen
and we can imagine that in special
spaces such as those
both guests and employees are very
sensitive to privacy
but in terms of pandemic prevention like
holding natural science right
or biological science in this case um to
to hunt um
you know failing to provide reliable
information for contact chasing would
lead to very significant vulnerability
so it looks like a a trade-off but uh
it's only a trade-off if you do not
innovate so we innovated uh the
government
did not invoke sanctions or order
nightclubs to close down
to to quarantine it um such measures
could of course strengthen
the uh public health scientists but it
also strengthens the stigma
society already attached to nightclub
workers and that also causes then the
business to go underground and that is
what happened during the
great prohibition in usa right and so
both situations would only substantially
make the public health situation even
i'm more
unpredictable because there's no
reliable data and the reliable data is
the foundation of trust
and so uh thanks to the fact that many
experts at the cecc in taiwan
already had extensive prior experience
with hiv
u equals u and so on and so these
experts devise a
practical system called the real contact
not real name so as long as people could
be effectively contact in case of
outbreak there's no real name necessary
and we also explain the scientific crux
which is physical distance it must be
maintained
to prevent droplet infections and so we
say as long as the nightclubs
achieve this local government could open
them up and so as a result the
businesses do
innovate such as leaving code name
single-use emails prepare mobile
numbers wearing hats with this plastic
shield to maintain physical distance i
can go on
and so even if even nightclubs could
join this scientific team of pandemic
fighting
then social trust would be much more
easily held
due to pandemic prevention this is about
empowering even nightclub workers
to be kind of like an amateur
epidemiologist and social innovator
it's such a fascinating structure
because you already have people sort of
operating in a semi anonymous
demi bond in some ways where they're
like they're already working
with with anonymizing because that's
what they build trust with their
clients with their customers that's
right that's fascinating i am thinking
about
the range of people's knowledge and
abilities in the us with how they work
with technology and even with
kids who we would say are the you know
are so great at
operating their devices and stuff and
they're so related to that
it does require giving people the
structure to learn
how to do this stuff you're not
necessarily teaching them how to code
but they have to learn uh
what the devices are capable of doing in
advance yeah and also the
the security uh parameters how to wield
code
uh responsibly and so on which is not
unlike you know the original technology
called fire and
how we teach fire use you know in the
primary classes uh it's called cooking
classes
the user interface with fire has to be
very carefully managed
exactly i want to bring that back around
especially to
thinking about the relationship with
covet 19.
taiwan had seen a coronavirus outbreak
once in advance and was prepared there
was some
readiness to deal with it as soon as it
became clear
that this could potentially be another
pandemic those structures have to be
built in advance too right like what
you're describing is a commitment
to to an infrastructure that just waits
and is prepared for any kind of change
in a way that i find myself very jealous
of right like you have to have that
stuff ready to deploy
before you know you're going to need it
well yes and no i mean uh
the structure the societal trust
structure need to be there
first obviously and that's as you said
what everybody above 30 years old anyway
remembering the stars 1.0
uh initial release which would help
because that there really builds uh like
a very strong incentive to
not go to the root of locking down uh
because we did
have a lockdown after hoping hospital
unannounced with no
determined like days to to end the
lockdown it was very traumatic
uh and so people when hearing about oh
sas 2.0
imminent release uh we we basically said
okay
we don't know the feature set but we
assume that it's the same as 1.0
and in which case uh we must strive uh
to quarantine at the borders and with no
lockdown uh if we can help it the idea
of a societal response system
that already trusts for example the
usefulness of mask wearing and so on
that's of course already the case but
the other system the technological
system the response systems and so on
were not
in place we basically built it in very
short order like within days
and we failed very publicly uh and then
uh when people call 1922 saying that hey
eurasian
musk uh but uh my boy only had pink
medical musk he doesn't want to wear it
to school you're depriving him of
education rights
or he will be bullied and so on and then
we remedied it very quickly right so 24
hours after
everybody in the cec daily press
conference wore pink medical mask in
solidarity and administration even said
pink panther was his childhood hero or
something and so the boy had become the
most hit boy in the class and that's
gender mainstreaming very
it's not to have the structure the
technological structure in place before
any um crisis it's just co-evolving with
the crisis to make sure that people see
whichever new idea they have that's
amplified in very short order weeks
or days or hours even and then you will
harness the energy that was
originally directed uh to the anxiety
and fear and doubt
into co-creation and co-creation is very
joyful right so the spokes dog
zonchai always publishes in a very cute
manner the physical distancing you know
going outdoors you have to maintain two
shiba you know somewhere
indoors three dogs away and once you
laugh about it you literally cannot feel
outraged again because it's two very
different emotional outlets and that's
the core of the co-creation strategy
called
humor overall it's been an obvious
success so far i hope it continues
mr arutan digital minister taiwan thank
you so much for doing this and for
explaining this it's a it's actually
quite hopeful i hope we
hope we figure out some of the same
things that you have in the us thank you
yeah thank you live long and prosper
prosperity and long life
[Music]
hi hi my name is dan are we
are we going bye
okay my name is dan duane i'm uh
i'm a journalist and i've been looking
into the wildfire situation in
california for a little over a year now
and uh i've learned quite a lot from our
to the two uh fire science returns
now david saw
a principal investigator a
fire scientist consortium called
hydrogens and a professor at the
university of san francisco
and leroy westerling a
professor at uh california
and working hey guys
hi how are you dan good good to see you
guys so
okay so i i'll just to sort of bring our
our listeners up to speed here we um
i got interested in this topic a couple
of years ago when
after the horrific fires of 2018 and i
had
i had about that time because i was kind
of go to the mountains a lot i had
noticed about a few million trees have
died in the mascara
and that that led me into kind of
discovering the
world that you guys lived in full time
are have been aware for quite a long
time that uh
we are already of
the sustainable uh violent
confrontations and likely heading into
the time of
and uh so one of the things i was sort
of most delighted to discover when i
connected
was a lot of that there's very real work
already being done
both make sense of kinds of fires
to figure out how to model them and to
make
potentially useful predictions for the
future about the kind of the kind we
might see
um and so to that end uh david why why
don't you
start a little by just telling us
telling us about the
um the genesis of pi regents
so um the california energy commission
put out a call to to help identify
um you know how how to build the next
generation of wildfire models
the state itself california itself is
dealing with wildfires on an
ongoing basis you see it in the news
it's a major problem
and it's a major problem not only for
the utilities but for people
and the environment and so what we ended
up doing there was a large
scientific community wildfire scientific
community
we decided to band together and and go
after this proposal as a large
consortium
in a way that's open and transparent and
where co-learning could occur
not only within the scientific community
itself but within
specific stakeholders starting with the
state the ious and the general public
it's very exciting uh it's it's building
a huge table that we're able to bring a
bunch of scientists around
in a transparent and open way to have
the hard conversations that are needed
in this this time of great change time
of great change in terms of
climate uh in terms of policies and in
terms of the environment itself
and and leroy uh how about telling me
about
so so you run one of uh
one of several working groups within
this consortium sort of research working
groups within the by regions consortium
um tell me tell me about uh
your working group and some of the sort
of big and difficult
unexplained questions about um or i'm
sorry unanswered questions some of the
the questions that uh that you you know
that you've been working to answer about
the wildfire predicament in california
sure so i leave work in group four
and working group four is basically
responsible for the long-term
projections so pi regions as a whole is
looking at everything from
analysis of historical extreme fires
and then you know hourly to multi-day
outlooks
seasonal forecasts and then long-term
projections out to the end of the 21st
century
and we are really tasked with
trying to understand how to resolve some
of the uncertainties
and allow the state and communities
across california
to manage risks around wildfire going
forward
and some of the some of the biggest
constraints have been
when we're doing these models we're
putting them together
based on what we understand about fires
in the recent past especially
because that's when we have the most
data but then we're projecting them
forward into a time
where the climate extremes can far
exceed what's been observed in the
recent past
so we have to understand not just how
well our models were
reproducing the past that we've observed
recently but how they behave in the
future
in novel climates and interaction
between
those novel climates and say how we
manage the landscape and
the future development footprint and so
some of the biggest challenges have been
how to incorporate things like
those lightning strikes that we had this
year
right you don't we don't predict where
lightning is going to strike but we have
to understand how that adds to that
to that variability and that risk or
there are tens of millions of dead trees
in the sierra nevada from the beetle
outbreaks and
and severe drought that we had in the
last decade
and so we're trying to understand how to
incorporate that into our modeling as
well so that we can
see um what future fires would look like
in these really
altered fuels from tens of millions of
dollars
so one of the one of the things that i i
think um
you know uh has perhaps not been
in my view quite enough of the public
conversation around wildfire in
california is that
you know we tend to look toward in the
media we tend to look toward fairly easy
metrics to measure how bad wildfires are
like by saying
the easiest one of course is sheer acres
burned
and yes our wildfires in california are
getting bigger
very quickly year after year in terms of
sheer acres burned
um but really they don't in terms of the
total acreage burned across the state
every year we're still pretty far behind
where california was as a natural system
100 years ago
in terms of annual acres burned and it
see it seems to me that in some ways
the the really more astonishing metric
and the one that tells us
more about why wildfire has become so
incredibly disruptive in our lives
in recent years is the sheer severity of
the fires that we're seeing the
uh the extreme rate of fire spread the
extreme
rate of energy release some sort of
strange weather phenomena around fire
um and so david
why don't you talk to me a little bit
about how those questions
you know how that aspect of fire change
in california plays into
uh the research that pi regents is doing
um
and uh and the sort of interesting
insights
yeah yeah that's a great question so
like i mean you you hit the nail on the
head it's you know the size and severity
of fire is important but the nature of
fire itself
how these large wildfires are changing
and evolving on the landscape is also
important and so you know leroy alleged
the fact that he's the lead
in our working group four which is
focused on our long-term projections
uh chris lautenberger is in charge of
our worker 3 which is in charge of our
short-term projections but the nature of
fire itself
we have broken up into two separate
working groups right we have one
janice cohen that's leading extreme fire
weather
right plume drop driven events what
creates that what causes them
what are the atmospheric climatological
conditions that are important to
understand when we look
uh at wildfire and the interactions with
the
with the weather now and with the
changing climate in the future
we also have another working group um
that's led by scott stevens uh john
battles and mark finney
that's looking at fuel loading right so
the fuel loading conditions are also
changing over time
and we're seeing that you know back to
what lyra was talking about
the loads and the force are are at a
level that
are you know outside of our historic
norms
and we don't have any points in history
where we could look to see examples of
it
so folks like finney are looking at
examples of like dresden or hiroshima
to look at firestorms that occurred in
those environments to see if they can
capture some of the physics
involved in that and see how we can
integrate that into our existing
understanding of wildfire models
you switch over to where janus is
looking at things and her group
it's not you know wildfires not
ubiquitous across the state you could
kind of think of it
in the most general terms as different
fire types what i like to call fire
nature
that are sprinkled across the different
state some of our models are really good
at nailing them down
uh the surface weather surface wind
driven events or rothmo based models
are pretty good at capturing them in the
simplest terms if you want to call plume
driven events
we don't have models that can capture
that we need to understand
the basic physics we need to build the
models right now to be able to scale up
and capture
um you know predictive
to clarify one thing for our for our
listeners that the
what we mean by plume driven events are
these uh are these wildfires that
become big enough that they're they
generate a big enough convective column
a big enough sort of
column of heat and smoke rising up from
the fire
that that column begins to generate its
own weather and it began and
most importantly it begins to drive
the the sort of core phenomenon is this
way in which it can drive
a sort of 360 degree radial wind field
into the fire itself so that as if the
fire has found a way to stoke itself
and to drive it you know hotter and
faster and
um and and leroy the um
and and so let's let's be sure to touch
on two things one is
you know leroy you've spent a lot of
time studying how climate change
uh interacts with um with our sort of
forest
management practices and wildfire
behavior so and i think one of the
questions that's been really getting
wrestled with a lot in the last
few weeks is is precisely that one so
how about airing out for us
the relationship between things like
forest management practices which is to
say
logging not logging thinning prescribed
burns
uh and and climate change and then
ultimately the kinds of fire behaviors
that we're seeing
yeah and i also want to address quickly
one thing you just said
when you're asking the question to david
and that was uh
saying comparing what we currently are
looking at to
uh yeah what you call the natural fire
regime and i think it's important to
keep in mind that
that was a fire regime that was also
managed by people
yeah and so a lot of the area additional
area burned in the state was
fires that were set to manage the
landscape for different objectives
and very different from the fires we're
seeing today
which are enhanced in some places by the
interaction between some of the
impacts of climate change and the legacy
of increased fuels on the landscape from
past fire suppression but also changes
in land use like grazing or
fragmentation of the landscape
and and so people often will point to
that fuels management
issue because it's a very graphically
obvious thing right if you look at
photographs of 100 years ago versus
today you can see really characteristic
changes
in the in the structure of forests
throughout the mid elevations of sierra
nevada
um and and those increased fuels there
have
made those forests more susceptible to
climate change
so as you warm up the planet right
you're evaporating more moisture this is
an arid region so there's not like an
excess reservoir of
moisture that can compensate for that
and we're not changing precipitation
that much
so far so so that's drawing
more moisture out of those ecosystems
out of those fuels and any places where
the
forest has gotten really overcrowded
shall we say
you have that exacerbated by competition
for moisture between the trees
in addition we have um increased
uh fraction of the precipitation that we
get comes as
rain unless it's snow and the snow melts
out earlier because there's less of it
often and because the
temperatures in spring are warmer so
that can make the fire season at higher
elevations come
earlier and then one of the factors
that's been really important
at lower elevations where most people in
california live and
typically not forested is
increased variability in precipitation
so as you warm up the planet you're
changing uh the temperature difference
between the higher latitudes in the
equator that changes the atmospheric
circulation patterns
and we often see uh in in projections
and
and now in some observations it's
increased frequencies or slower
weather patterns set up you know wet or
dry
cold or hot for a longer period of time
and that just increases the extremes
and in particular we've seen in recent
years
a lot of uh autumns where
the typical timing for fall
precipitation
changes and instead of getting a big
storm that comes in
in northern and southern california and
sort of shuts down the fire season
in terms of big severe fires
the fire season can extend weeks or
months later into the
into the fall and even the winter and as
that's
happening the probability of a big wind
event is increasing
the later you get in the year just
because of the change in the seasons
and and so we get these big wind-driven
events in the fall
in addition to these more plume-driven
events like we
were seeing this summer and so all these
things are interacting on landscape in
different places
and basically you have these fuels that
are much drier for much longer
interacting with the timing of
precipitation and winds in the fall
and and uh producing you know actually a
fairly complex situation it's not just
like one
factor dominates
and hey we have we have a question yeah
we have one question
bring it in one question from michael
mike aaron asks what major economic and
human migration
shifts do you see in the next 10 years
due to global climate change and and
feel free to apply that to the wildfire
situation
in california of course not globally
just specifically in california well you
know wherever you want to go
well i think so for us it's useful just
focus on california because
that's our topic here but
um it's not clear to me that people are
going to abandon
the wildline urban interface or more
rural areas of california just because
of fire
it might be because of a combination of
say insecure water supply and
increased fire risks playing out in some
rural communities for example but uh
california is a big state it's got a
housing crisis
a shortage of housing it's expensive to
live in the coastal
cities uh and then things like covet are
putting pressure on people to sort of
spread out more instead of
consolidated in already urbanized areas
so it's hard to tell you know how how
that would play out
but if we're going to stay in these
rural communities and in these
smaller cities and towns that are in
embedded in
in fuels in risky places like
paradise and santa rosa have been in
recent
in the news in recent years we need to
learn how to
manage that risk better and that means
that we need
to quantify it right if you if you're
going to get homeowners insurance it's
going to cover your fire risk
the whoever is providing that insurance
needs to be able to anticipate what the
risk
actually is and if there are ways to
mitigate it you know what are the
characteristics of homes and communities
the spatial footprint how we build them
how the vegetation around them is
managed that make them more or less
robust to wildfire risks that
that's something that we need to get a
better handle on and that's a
forward-looking thing we can't
concentrate on just what we've
understood from looking at say the past
five years past 10 years past 20 years
it has to be science-based projection
into the future because the climate
system that underlies all of these
these fire risks and the ecosystem
that supports fire
is is shifting rapidly because of
the legacy of uh i'm sorry we gotta
we're out of time
i'm sorry to do that i'm sorry we're out
of time
thanks a lot gentlemen uh you know i
look forward to more in the future
okay guys take care thank you bye thank
you
hello that was a marvelous day
so many great conversations marvelous
event
all three days we did i learned all
kinds of things
new ideas interesting people i kept
coming back today
to an idea that lisa piccarello talked
about and she's explaining how
she solved the conway not problem and a
problem that no one had been able to
solve
forever and she solved it in a week how
did she do it
well she knew that if two not share the
same four-dimensional space
they're both either sliced or not sliced
so
instead of looking at the conway not
what if she built another knot
and then analyzed it then she could
figure out the condom
it was an amazing way it was an amazing
metaphor
for this whole event if there's a
problem and it's an unsolvable problem
how do you turn it around how do you
look at it in a new way
and that was kind of the message of so
many of our conversations and the theme
that ran through the problem today
in so many so many different ways was
trust right
how can you trust the government to keep
us safe in corona virus how can you
trust
a vaccine how can you trust what's on
your computer screen
is real how can you trust the election
results how can you trust that the news
you're getting about coronavirus
is safe and then ultimately how can we
trust
each other to keep ourselves safe from
coronavirus and how can we emulate
what's happened in taiwan it was an
extraordinary set of new ways
of looking at different elements of the
same problem and it was great
counter programming to the debate last
night which was all about
breaking trust the reason so many of us
were dissatisfied was the sense that the
message from that conversation was
it's time to break trust with the
american election or with the justice
system
and so to have today new ways of looking
at new problems
new ways of understanding trust i
thought was great
so thank you so much to everybody who
participated thank you to our moderators
thank you to our speakers thank you to
our spot
together globally there's a support
wheel to create
wire25 and thank you to all of you for
watching sticking through it
sending questions
[Music]
so
you